this presentation is delivered by the
stanford center for professional
development
so now before we start the webinar i
would like to introduce
um to take the opportunity to introduce
karissa little
who will be hearing who will you who you
will be hearing from later today
carissa little is the director for
professional programs at the stanford
center for professional development
she has been with stanford university
for 10 years and is responsible for
collaborating with stanford faculty
industry experts
and corporate partners to develop the
professional and executive programs that
extend stanford to industry
she worked in both software and
education prior to coming to stanford
i agree varal who will be the speaker
today is the co-director of the stanford
innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate
he is the ethel mcbean professor of
organizational behavior and human
resource at the stanford graduate school
of business
he teaches courses such as human
resource management
and teaches within two executive
programs
he has published widely in the field of
management and sociology
and studies the social and cultural
causes organizat of organizational
change
his recent work investigates the role of
social movements
as motors of organizational change in
professional and organizational fields
rao has drawn on his knowledge and
expertise to conduct workshops for
british petroleum
mcdonald's bristol myers general
electric
microsoft the fbi and the intelligence
comp
community so now with that i'd like to
turn the floor over to professor
hayagriva rao
good morning everybody my name is haya
gribarao
and i'm a professor at stanford's
graduate school of business
it's a delight with you to be with you
this morning
the theme of today's webinar is killing
ideas
is way more important than collecting
um let me signal what the main
proposition i'd like to advance for all
of you to think about
often when we think about innovation we
think about
gathering as many ideas from people as
possible
my contention is gathering is the
easiest part
it's killing that's the hardest part and
when i say killing
i mean killing ideas of course
the problem is in most companies
we have a large supply of ideas in fact
we have more ideas than we can usually
implement
firms of course have very few resources
and the ideas
vary enormously in quality and that's
exactly why
we have to select ideas what would you
like to do
would you like to allocate dollars among
ten good ideas where you give ten
dollars for each good idea or would you
like to pick
two great ideas and put fifty dollars in
each of those ideas to ensure that they
work
so killing ideas is a very very
important part
of the innovation process
unfortunately however in most companies
the way we go about organizing the
process of killing
ideas is such that it hinges in a
committee
often referred to as the murder board
and what does the motorboat do
the murder boat not only kills the ideas
but invariably also subjects
those proposing the ideas to ridicule
humiliation and rejection
thereby killing their initiative as a
result
what happens is others who watched
what's happened to their peers
become even reluctant to supply ideas or
submit ideas
to the screening process or to any other
forum
that the organization might have the sad
result is
that organizations that have hired very
smart people
organize a process of killing ideas such
that
these very smart people become dumb
and when i say dumb i don't mean stupid
smug people of course stay smart they
might even become smarter
what i mean by being dumb is they become
mute they become silent i submit to you
that the central challenge in organizing
innovation for any enterprise
is the silence of its employees
particularly
its smart employees so that's really why
we really need to think very carefully
about
how to organize the process of killing
ideas
in fact one might argue that the larger
the firm
the greater are the rules the
constraints
uh you know the maze of toll gates and
committees and what have you
and the more likely is it that the smart
people hired
by very large enterprises they actually
become
silent and mute participants
the outcome of course was wonderfully
stated by
one of my favorite playwrights george
bernard shaw
i went to jesuit school many years ago
in india
and george bernard shaw certainly was a
staple of our education
and what i recall from that education
was a very memorable line
uttered by george bernard shaw and as he
put it few people think
more than two or three times a year i
have made
an international reputation for myself
by thinking
once or twice a week so
that's really our challenge how do we
design a process
for killing ideas in organizations
such that people think as often as they
can
and as often as they should and here
what i mean by thinking is
somewhat different presumably from what
the conception you might entertain some
of you might entertain
we often consider thinking to be a verb
the thinking is an adverb you think when
you do something
so how do we think we think when we talk
to ourselves
we think when we read a book we think
when we compose an email
we think when we're in a group and we
think in meetings and that's how
organizations actually
think let me provoke you
with a very interesting study conducted
by mckinsey in 2007.
the study's gold was very simple goal
had a very the study had a very simple
goal
namely to ask or to find out what is the
greatest predictor of innovation
performance
and what mckinsey did was they actually
surveyed
executives and managers in a variety of
industries
at very different levels in the
organization
so the first response
as you can see from this slide is
many people said look metrics and
measures
are the most important and of course we
need clear criteria
we need success metrics we need gold
criteria to make
go no go decisions and to have the
ability to discontinue projects
but as the metrics pyramid indicates
it's also the smallest
in size after all what's the use of
metrics and measures
if you don't have ideas to begin with in
the first place
and that's why the idea generation
pyramid
is much larger than the metrics and
measures pyramid and where do we get
ideas from
we get ideas from a variety of sources
often by observing customers directly
um that's consumer observation
helps us figure out what is it that
frustrates consumers
what is it that pisses them off what is
it that makes them curse
about the experience what's very
important is
when we find out what consumers are
cursing about we know that there is a
problem worth
solving and not only is it a problem
worth solving
it's also a problem where when you solve
it the consumers are willing to of
course pay for it as well
um so ideas certainly are important very
important
but how are ideas possible they don't
just come
simply when you observe consumers you
need a climate within the enterprise
a climate that actually allows for
experimentation
that allows for risk-taking and that
allows for knowledge sharing
and that is exactly why the climate
pyramid is
larger than the idea generation pyramid
and so we're left with the question of
course of where does this climate come
from
and it comes uh of course from the
leadership of the enterprise
and that's why the leadership pyramid is
really the largest pyramid
and what leaders ought to have of clear
priorities
they ought to be able to protect and
buffer innovation
from constant interference and
excessive if you will evaluation that
might very well be premature now
mckinsey did a very interesting thing as
well
in their survey they actually asked
people at the very apex of the
enterprise
in the c-suite they asked them what do
you think is the biggest problem of
innovation
in the firm and strikingly
people in the c-suite said their
challenge was
the shortage of ideas in fact many of
them
said we have resources we have lots of
money we have lots of people but we have
very few
ideas uh in a very nice move mckinsey
went down several steps in the hierarchy
and they asked people what do you think
is the biggest bottleneck of innovation
and people said the bottleneck is very
clear
uh it's at the very top of the
enterprise it's leadership that's the
botanic
uh in fact in a completely different
executive program that i was teaching
here at the
graduate school of business here at
stanford one participant
uh put it very nicely he said professor
rao the bottleneck of course is always
at the top of the bottle and there you
have it you have a classic catch-22
you have the people at the apex of the
enterprise who say
we don't have ideas and people if you
will
in the lower uh levels closer to the
front line who say
the bottleneck of course is at the top
of the bottle
and the real question then is how do we
actually resolve
this catch-22 and this is exactly why
designing the process of killing ideas
is really the most
important thing in any enterprise
instead of inundating you with study
after study
i thought it might be homeless to
consider the example of one striking
organization
allow me to take a sip of water
this is a company called right solutions
they're based in rhode island
excuse me
um our case writer david hoyt
who's a brilliant case writer i might
add
we thought we ought to write a case
study about the company because when we
met the ceo
and the ceo both of them told us
they weren't the smartest people in the
company
i recalled gary vividly meeting the ceo
jim lavoy and he said
um professor rao i'm not the smartest
person in this company
there are many other smarter people we
then met the ceo and he occurred the
same thing and i said
well if you guys aren't the smartest
guys in the company
what exactly is it that you do and
that's when they
said that their role as leaders was
really to organize the process
uh for killing ideas and their vehicle
their mechanism
to do this was they created a stock
market for collective genius
that they called mutual fund note the
main
it's mutual fund and it's not mutual
fund so if the fund is important
it's not the fund that's important
a couple of things about uh right
solutions
uh right solutions is a company with
approximately at the time
when we visited them 155 employees or so
they are located in rhode island
connecticut and california
they specialize in computer
visualization uh
and computer imaging services their
clients are casinos primarily in las
vegas
and the other big customer is the
department of defense particularly the
navy
who needs a lot of underwater
surveillance
equipment to deter potential terrorists
so those are the two clients that the
right solutions
actually serves let's take a closer look
at how they went about
organizing the stock market for
collective genius
as a mechanism to kill ideas and as
you'll see
what's interesting about the process is
it's one where
instead of discouraging cutting off
oxygen for the future supply of ideas
in fact it actually nourishes the supply
of ideas
so that ideas can be selected and the
company can really sort of execute
mutual fund at right solutions is
organized on the basis of
some very simple principles every
employee is given ten thousand dollars
of opinion money
and what an employee can do with this
opinion money is to buy
savings bonds a savings bond of course
is any cost
saving idea issued by an employee
employees in addition to purchasing
savings bonds can also purchase
tasks stocks are of two types
one type of stock is called the bow
jones
this means it's a new product idea for
existing customers
namely casinos on the one hand and the
navy on the other
there's another category of stocks
called spasdac
which means these are far out new
product ideas for completely new
customers
customers that write solutions hitherto
had no experience in serving
now what's interesting about the mutual
fund
uh and the way it's implemented at right
solutions is
every employee with an idea can develop
and expect
this it's exactly the analog of a
prospectus in the stock market
what can you do with your expectance you
can't take it and simply put it on the
stock market
instead you would have to get the
support uh
some of this of one of the senior
engineers in the company these are
people called prophets
now you might ask why is it that they
require
a person with an idea to get the support
of a prophet
the answer is simple they don't want
litter in the ideal landscape of the
enterprise
if there is no filter if there is no
sensor
all kinds of ideas tend to get put on
the marketplace
and when people see the landscape
littered with debris
nobody wants to visit the landscape it's
very much like seeking to visit a garden
with a lot of litter why would we want
to do that and that's exactly why
they actually have a filter now what can
other employees do
once they see a savings bond or a stock
they can buy the stock
they can use any of their opinion money
of ten thousand dollars to purchase the
stock or savings bond
in addition every savings bond or stock
has a discussion thread
so uh for instance if one of you comes
up with an idea that says hey
um you know why are we
paying at why are we at right solutions
paying telecommunication firms
uh money for a pabx system why can't we
do it ourselves
uh you know i might come up with a
suggestion or you might come up with the
suggestion
but neither of us might know how to
write the code and implement it and
somebody else might actually say
well here are five ways to implement the
code uh
another person might say wait a minute
this is actually a savings bond or a
cost saving idea
why can't we make it about jones and
actually offer this service
of course to our casinos so in which
case something that was a savings bond
quickly moves into the
dow jones category most of all what
employees can do in addition to
purchasing stocks and offering
suggestions
is that they can volunteer time now here
right solutions follows a very
interesting policy instead of
informing employees that they can
allocate 80 percent of their time to
regular work
and 20 of their time to something like
mutual fund
right solutions does not actually uh
stipulate such a policy instead the
premise is
100 of your time you have to work on
regular projects because you do actually
have regular projects
that you have to work on for the navy or
for the casinos or whosoever
contracts the services of right
solutions so if you want to really work
in mutual fund
you really have to work using your own
time sometimes a weekend sometimes after
work hours
and the premise behind that is if it's
valuable enough for you
to use your weekend time or your
afternoon you know after hours time
that means the idea itself is
sufficiently compelling to you
sufficiently worthwhile for you to
actually invest the time and energy
that you require now one of the striking
things i must confess
when we were writing the case study and
when we were visiting
the right solutions at rhode island
excuse me
i apologize i have a little bit of a
golden cough so you might hear an
occasional golden cough throughout
as i was mentioning one of the striking
things uh that i found certainly when
david hoyt and i were at
the offices of right solutions was after
meeting the ceo we actually met the
receptionist of the firm
and what was astonishing was the
receptionist actually had
two savings ons ideas on the stock
market
and think of this how many companies can
have any of you been to where the firm
says
my receptionist is a person with ideas
and these ideas are worthwhile
uh for us to actually consider um uh you
know
in our ideal landscape as it were
i was completely astonished uh by the
fact that the receptionist had
two such ideas both of them were savings
bonds they actually had to do
um if i recall with a company credit
card
now the next slide kind of gives you a
quick sense of the stock headlines
that an employee sees when they actually
log in to the right solutions
uh stock market the headlines sort of
look like that
they actually tell you uh you know
what are the you know stock buckets as
it were
where is help wanted what are the new
investment opportunities
and the like uh one very important thing
uh in this market there is no short
selling you cannot short someone else's
stock
so the idea here is not to denigrate a
stock as much as
uh to actually purchase it or not
purchase it and of course
the way ideas get killed is when nobody
purchases your stock
nobody offers a suggestion and nobody
volunteers
what's very important about the right
solutions system is
instead of a committee killing the idea
it's the community that kills an idea
what's also equally important is
what happens to rejected ideas they
don't
languish they don't atrophy they don't
disappear
they actually become the raw materials
of course to construct new ideas
because one idea by itself simply may
not be enough
one rejected idea when combined with
another idea and another idea and
another idea
might actually make for an interesting
innovation
i'm actually showing you in the next
slide the
portfolio of jim lavoy the ceo at the
time when
you know we wrote the case study and as
you can see
his personal portfolio is divided into
three columns
uh column one is savings bonds there are
a number of things
you know company credit card and the
like uh then there are a bunch of bao
jones ideas you will see that the stock
market itself
is about jones idea you know employees
who actually develop
mutual funds said hey why can't we
actually offer this to a bunch of other
people and then you actually have
spasdak
ideas for completely new products all
together
and you can see that there are many more
bow jones ideas
more savings bonds and dare i say fewer
spat stack ideas
um and another striking thing of course
is
you will see if you total up what is in
the savings bond column
the dow jones column and the star stack
column the total exceeds ten thousand
dollars and the reason of course is
as employees volunteer as they buy stock
the value of the stock
naturally rises in the enterprise a word
about spasdak
ideas uh it's very hard for anybody to
come to you and say hey
come up with a far out idea for a new
customer i mean that's not a meaningful
instruction or a meaningful mandate or a
meaningful charter
instead the way employees had write
solutions develop
spastec when they go about solving
problems in their daily lives
so let me illustrate it with a striking
example
there was actually a young software
designer she had two kids
um and i think one of the kids who i
believe was 10 years old or so came to
her and said mom
uh you know i have to teach my class
about soils
and you know earth and soils they seem
to be a boring subject how can i make
this interesting
and this employee who was a mom quickly
thought about it and said ah
i could use a software engine to develop
um a little bingo game
where students can participate and
you know gather knowledge about soils in
a fascinating way
and it worked really well the first time
when she tried it in her 10 year old's
class then she actually went to the
younger daughter's class
and tried it there and then there the
teacher actually told the younger
daughter's class told her that was one
of the most exciting days in her life
and that's when this young lady actually
went to one of the prophets and of
course
it actually got put on mutual fund and
what's amazing is
this idea that they developed eventually
got sold to
hasbro the toy company and what's
amazing is
hasbro the toy company their r d unit is
four miles from where the headquarters
of right solutions was located
what's even more interesting of course
is
that people had never considered this
toy maker
to be a customer even though it was so
close because they were so focused
on casinos and the department of defense
and you can see how
an idea generated by somebody in the
enterprise actually
was interesting enough for a toy
manufacturer
to consider this to be of value to them
and consider this to be of relevance
to them since then the time manufacturer
of course has become one of their
customers
and that's what spastech ideas
continually do over time
so what does the company do with this
idea market as you can well imagine
instead of the boss picking the top best
ideas
they actually rely on the top 15 stocks
in the stock market
and this slide gives you a quick visual
of a variety of
stocks that were in play at that time
and what the company does is
it puts real money and they have a
lovely phrase to describe it they call
it
adventure capital and not venture
capital uh they put this money
uh to to implement the ideas contained
in these
uh stocks so i asked jim lavoy the ceo
and his colleague the ceo why don't you
guys choose
the stocks and they tell you look you
know we're not the smartest people we
can't figure out
which of these stocks is really going to
work and that's exactly why
they rely on the stock market
the next slide hopefully gives you an
overview of employee participation
so you can see over a period of time and
this was actually over an 18-month
period
a large fraction of employees began to
participate
in the stock market of course all of
them aren't generating ideas some of
them
are others actually might be commenting
on other people's ideas
most important many might actually be
volunteering on ideas
developed by other people and in fact
one of the amazing things
that both the ceo and the ceo of right
solutions can do is
they can instantly tell you who the best
citizens of the company are
and how do they know they actually can
tell you who participates most who
comments most
uh on the ideas of other people and
who of course volunteers
on the ideas of other people and these
people actually get a reward
by the way when ideas succeed all of the
people who've been involved in
developing the idea get a reward
and it's not necessary always that the
originator gets the most reward you
might originate an idea
but you might not know how to implement
it and there may be others
who might actually have done the heavy
lifting and they get
a share of the rewards that is
corresponding to their contribution
and the next slide gives you a quick
overview at right solutions
about the growth of stocks in the
company the blue line is the total
number of stocks in the company
the orange line gives you the number of
savings bonds ideas in the company
the green line is the number of dow
jones ideas
and the purple line gives you
an idea of the number of spasdac ideas
and as you can well imagine
uh cost saving ideas predominate
followed by
bow jones ideas uh followed by
spastak ideas but look at the numbers
for an organization of 150 people or so
there are 50 plus ideas in the market
this
of course doesn't include ideas that
have been sold off to other people
because for a company with 150 people
it's very hard for them to implement
each and every idea
so one of the things they're doing right
now is they're shrink wrapping these
ideas as it were
and selling the ip to somebody else uh
because they can't implement them
but nonetheless 50 ideas listed in a
market in a company with 150 or so
employees means for every three
employees
they have one actionable idea and that
is astonishing
if you would ask me every firm
has if you will a defining symbol um
for instance if you walk into the
headquarters of qualcomm in san diego
you when you go to the lobby you may not
see pictures but instead you might
actually see
um patents that the company has acquired
over time and what
the lobby with all of the patents
signals to you is we believe of course
that knowledge matters that knowledge is
the most central asset of the enterprise
and um that is exactly what the design
of the lobby communicates
what is striking at right solutions is
when you walk into their lobby
they actually have a puzzle on the floor
in fact on the carpet
and that's the puzzle that's out there
in front of you in the slide
the puzzle is in red and blue
and jim lavoy the ceo says along with
his colleague the ceo
says look the red is all the
questions that an employee has
the blue is what the company ought to be
thinking about and his point is
if you really want to engage employees
in
participating in innovation you need to
get them to contribute but you need to
get them to contribute by answering all
of these questions
jim's point is very simple excuse me he
says any company
asks of an employee can this person do
the job
and of course the employee in turn asks
can i do this job and shall i behave
and what that creates is the basis for a
transactional relationship
jim's point is if you really want to
create a culture of innovation
you really ought to answer all the other
questions that an employee has
am i important are they asking me are
they listening to me
do i belong do they care about me are
they recognizing me are they rewarding
me not just for existing employees but
conceivably alumni as well
and in turn if the company answers these
questions it has to actually signal
that they care and trust employees that
they think about the future and they
really want the employees
to contribute to the future at right
solutions one of the interesting things
is when you join the company
on day one by 4 pm you have access to
all of the intellectual property of the
company
because you can actually see everything
on mutual fund
in an unrestricted manner of course if
you ask them
uh what are the core processes that
sustain right solutions they will tell
you there are two core processes one is
how we hire people they're very careful
about the kinds of people who
who they hire and the second core
process they will tell you
is the process of course for killing
ideas and the guts of which is
this is the market called mutual fund
i i wanted to give you a very granular
and detailed account of one company so
that you understand
how the process of killing ideas works
and i thought this is actually the
appropriate time for us to sort of back
away a little bit
and see right solutions in a larger
context
and if we step back from right solutions
and look at firms in a larger context um
let's actually start with defining what
an innovative organization is
any innovative organization has three
characteristics and this slide indicates
that the three characteristics are
its ability to generate ideas its
ability to select ideas and its ability
to
implement ideas so you need to have lots
of ideas you gotta
select them and you gotta execute them
the point of course as we saw in right
solutions is
our ability to do all of these three
things hinges
crucially decisively on how we design
the process for killing ideas in fact
the process for killing ideas is one
that
actually can play a big role in in
viewing the enterprise with the will to
innovate
and it can also constitute a set of
social tools
for people to innovate and most
importantly it can actually be
a system for evaluating ideas let's take
a look at each of those circles
the circles of the will the circles of
ideas and the circles of tools
so what's interesting at right solutions
is
mutual fun on the one hand sustains the
will to innovate
it is a tool to innovate it is also a
system to
gather and of course kill our ideas at
the same time
so let's take a look at will some of you
when the word will is mentioned might
think of philosophers
like russo or hobbes or john locke
but i'm a social scientist and for me
the will to innovate is very behavioral
when i go to an organization
i typically look at four things and
they're at the right extreme of this
slide
under the label will and for me i know
that a company has the will to innovate
when i go to meetings and i see
employees asking questions
when you actually observe employees
sharing knowledge and information
when you see employees taking risks and
when of course you see employees
borrowing
from other companies so those really are
the four manifestations the behavioral
realizations of will
if you will
how are these four behavioral
manifestations will produced in an
enterprise
and if we summarize 40 years of research
uh what all of that research
can be distilled down to is that four
emotional experiences are at the core
of the will to innovate one is the
feeling of psychological safety
the second is the feeling that you trust
the firm and the firm trusts you
the third is a feeling of fun and the
fourth is the feeling of confidence
and what this slide shows is how those
four feelings as it were
drive uh innovation by fostering the
will to innovate and
produce and underpin all of the four
manifestations
uh of the will to innovate so a word
about each of these things
psychological safety means i feel safe
in my workplace nobody's going to make
fun of me nobody's going to ridicule me
trust means i trust the enterprise and
the enterprise trusts me so it right
solutions having access to all the ip is
one
indicator if you will of trust and the
other thing is innovation isn't a chore
it's fun it's uplifting it's energetic
and then the other piece is that there
is confidence
uh in the enterprise
so how can you actually develop all of
this
i'm going to focus on the willingness to
take risks and something that
companies can do very easily to ensure
that they they sustain the will to
innovate is
to figure out when they can kill ideas
uh and here
what this slide that depicts is a simple
graph on the y-axis you have the cost of
an error or a mistake
and on the x-axis you have the cost of a
price you have the project timeline
and of course the later you kill an idea
uh the more resources by then you would
have presumably poured into it
and so the costlier it is for you to
kill the idea
you might in fact even be reluctant to
only for it to go to the marketplace and
then be killed
in this instance by consumers of course
when that happens
the rest of the enterprise becomes gun
shy because they've seen one big failure
and they become very hesitant to take
risks instead the smart thing of course
is
to actually kill ideas as early as
possible so
one of the ways you can do it is to
prototype and fail fast and one of the
nice things that right solutions does is
they kill ideas from for example at the
profit stage if you don't get the
support of one person
ideas disappear there even if they're
listed
if nobody is actually buying the stock
if nobody's
discussing this talk or coming up with
ideas to improve the
basic premise behind this talk or
volunteering
ideas get killed there as well and so
the earlier you kill an idea the much
better it is and so that's kind of an
important
thing to keep in mind
uh let me then quickly sort of move on
to borrowing borrowing is a very
important part of
the will to innovate you know a lot of
ideas that are new
are actually borrowed i mean in fact you
can think of
the andon card system at toyota where
workers in a factory
pull a cord in order to stop the
production train where did the designer
of the toyota system of production get
the
idea from obviously by observing people
in a bus or a train because that's what
we do
in order to get the bus or the train to
stop so there are many ways in which we
can actually
you know borrow so you can actually get
uh
you know your workers to go through
sabbaticals uh milken in south carolina
sends its
uh manufacturing supervisor to every new
customer
when they ship a product there for the
first time to go figure out how do they
use our product and what is it we can
learn that can actually kind of help us
improve
so what's important is you really need
to sustain a high trial rate
you want people to keep coming up with
ideas and
here's jeff bezos at amazon he has a
monthly reward
for employees who act without getting
permission first and this is a great
example to tell people look
you don't need to be hemmed in by rules
rules don't need to sap your
initiative quite the contrary uh so keep
trying with ideas
let's move to um uh ideas then and as
you can see this slide
gives you uh four simple things about
ideas ideas need to be generated
an idea by itself may be of little use
and therefore
idea an idea might have to be combined
with another idea it then has to be
selected and then has to be executed
and the point of this slide is to say
the system for doing so
once again has to be predicated on these
four core emotions
if people feel unsafe they don't trust
the enterprise it's not fun they don't
have confidence
they're not going to generate ideas
instead they're always going to wait for
your approval as a boss
they're not going to speak up they're
not going to say very much so ideas are
going to go
begging because they're actually going
to remain in the heads of employees
they're going to be most importantly
unspoken
and never come into the spoken realm of
the enterprise
right solutions isn't the only paradigm
or way to organize the process of
killing ideas
here's whirlpool and they take an
internal venture capital approach
and what this slide shows you is um
whirlpool has a pipeline if you ask them
what is your
innovation portfolio they'll tell you
look we actually have
a whole bunch of business concepts and
these are
you know simple ideas for which funding
is given very easily often
a team of two or three people can get
together they can write a page
and then they can ask for funds and
these funds are very readily provided
uh you know you can actually think of
these if you will
as five thousand dollar sort of ideas if
they work
uh you know your business concept can
flower into an experiment
and you will of course have far fewer
experiments because ideas are being
killed at this stage as well
and then the experiment you will receive
of course more money than five thousand
dollars
to you know see if your experiment works
and of course if your experiment works
you can actually go to the prototype
stage and you can see that the number of
prototypes are far fewer
than the number of experiments and if
your prototype works you can actually
scale up
and actually enter the market so that's
another way to kind of organize
innovation in any enterprise let me
close with a quick account of social
tools
in any enterprise for it to be
innovative you need tools to connect to
mobilize to evaluate and simplify
and mutual fund does all of that it
connects people into a community it
mobilizes teams you don't even need to
appoint a team
it's a system for evaluating ideas and
it's very simple
there are three buckets three actions
that you can take
and the actions are buy discuss
volunteer
and once again it actually depends on
the core emotions of safety trust
fund and confidence you of course need
the high trial rate
uh as i've sort of mentioned again this
is an example
of a company called the alabama gas
company it is i believe
since then been acquired at one time the
ceo used to give out
visiting cards to employees when he
visited them one side had the name of
the card
the name of the ceo and the other side
was a get out of jail card
and what the ceo would do each time he
gave his visiting card to his employees
was he would tell them
try an idea if it doesn't work turn the
card in nothing will happen to you
and his point is i don't want them to
quit even before they've tried anything
and i sort of want to make sure they
actually contribute to
the idea generation process so hopefully
that has given you enough material
for you to think about why
designing the process to kill ideas in
fact
uh is the very foundation to gather
ideas and to actually implement them and
i'm going to turn things over to
my colleagues here so that they can
actually give you some more information
after which i understand we can actually
take some questions
yes well thank you so much for that um
insightful presentation
um before i begin my session i'm this is
carissa little here
i'd like to really encourage you to
submit questions throughout my
portion of today's presentation because
we will be hosting a question and answer
session with professor rao
so we at stanford are really pleased to
be offering the innovation and
entrepreneurship
certificate program in partnership with
academic directors professor rao and
professor sutton
this is a new certificate that we
launched in september of this year and
it was designed
for managers engineers and leaders of
innovation teams or any team that wishes
to be innovative
as well as entrepreneurs or
entrepreneurs or those that aspire to be
so
along with professionals and project
teams really in both public or private
organizations or enterprises
the school of engineering and the
graduate school of business decided to
partner to create this offering because
we've been hearing for
quite some time that organizations
really struggle both with innovation
and entrepreneurship and how to make
those things routine within their
organizations
we've designed a custom interface that
allows for interactivity
and collaboration in a self-paced
environment there are assignments with
ta feedback
so that we can ensure that there's
content retention the certificate
program requires
students to complete eight courses in
order to earn the entire certificate
i also wanted to highlight some upcoming
innovation offerings that we have you
can see here we have a couple of
webinars
in november and january and there's some
details there we're
very uh lucky to have jeffrey moore
joining us on november 28th
and perry clavon and jeremy utley who
are co-teaching of
a very interactive course will be
hosting a webinar on january 29th and
that course will launch
in and around the same time frame as
that webinar
i also want to highlight that we have a
new course here as a part of the
stanford innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate creating demand which is
taught by linda kate smith and donna
nowitzki
and so there's some details there if
you'd like to
to pursue that further
so i'd like to just take a moment we
really appreciate you
participating in this webinar and we
hope to get some feedback from you
about your level of interest in the
stanford innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate
we'll keep the polls open for a few
moments here
thank you very much for that feedback
um and with that i'm going to do some
question and answers here
give me a moment to get a couple of the
questions ready
um so professor rao
what do you think would be the limit of
this mechanism in terms of the number of
ideas and employees
in a scalable uh that's scalable across
multiple countries
and global countries or global companies
exclusion says it has 115
very important to the success of
something like this
you want to scale type of an idea
generation mechanism in a large global
enterprise
which has many divisions many sub units
it would not make sense to have one
right solutions for the entire firm
instead what you need are many such
right solutions
for small such units reason is simple
when you have actually 150 employees you
can imagine
what's going to happen in that small
unit
namely um this will be the subject of
corridor conversations
water cooler talk coffee table talk and
so forth
in a large enterprise if it's simply put
there the easiest
thing for people to do is to say let
somebody else do it
and so what you want to do is to kind of
make sure
you actually size it properly this you
know small
subunits very very important for you to
uh think about that and by the way the
other
very important thing to keep in mind is
uh the culture of the company of course
uh also ought to be important if you
have a culture where mistakes are lethal
mistakes are fatal it's very hard to
kind of do something like this
you need to sort of make sure you move
from a mistake culture if you will to a
prototype culture
well thank you our next question here
professor rao how do you see these types
of ideas work in more mature
organizations
say those with the size of a fortune 500
company
so as i was mentioning a little while
ago for a fortune 500 company
part of what you would want to do is to
use this type of a system
as a complement to existing things
large organizations love the idea of
innovation
jams and so on where the entire
enterprise
congregates together once or often they
think about things such as innovation
contests that are once a year kind of
events
and this is sort of much more organic
much more kind of natural
and once again what's very important is
how you structure the enterprise
so there's a very famous
idea sometimes referred to as dunbar's
law
and what robin dunbar was an
anthropologist and
studied the baboons chimpanzees gorillas
and human beings
and calculated that the optimal size of
the band for human beings
was 148.7 and his point was
villages would begin to subdivide at
that point in time tribes would
begin to subdivide at that point in time
and dunbar's notion was that when you
actually got to 150
you actually needed to devote a lot of
attention to what he referred to as
grooming activity
so if you think of chimpanzees what do
they do they groom each other they comb
their hair
you know they do all of this of course
we human beings don't do all of that we
have
um you know if you're good language and
most importantly we have cultural
rituals that bind us together
the point is in organizations that are
smaller sized
it's easy to create these sorts of
rituals that glue the company together
and then actually have
something like right solutions
to to to serve as a mechanism to uh
build and extend uh you know uh
the cultural behaviors of people in the
company uh
in a large mature organization um
you know where you have lots of rules
and so forth
you might even use something like right
solutions as a great way of killing
rules
rules that actually get in the way of
innovation you could even make that fun
too
that's interesting so it's sort of in
contrast there's a question here
um about how can an early stage
entrepreneur
kill ideas when they don't have the
luxury of affording many employees
that's a great question um
the way you know entrepreneurs can
actually you know kill ideas in a
startup and if i understand the question
correctly is
by interacting with consumers or at
least
potential consumers um that's often a
great way to
not kill ideas as much as modify ideas
uh you know prototypes are based on a
startup
and you know our startups rather are
based on a prototype
and what you have with your prototype or
idea is you test it with consumers
you quickly figure out their willingness
to buy their willingness to pay
that's a simple way to to do that and
the nice thing about
startups of course is everybody is doing
everything
it's a very small organization as one
person
as one writer likened the startups to
you know beach volleyball there isn't a
whole lot of bench strength
people are playing together they're
improvising
and so often customer feedback might be
a very nice way to
to to ensure that you kill ideas so
the point of course for a startup here
is uh even with few people you can
actually get interesting ideas as well
provide that you've actually hired these
people very carefully
great and one final question here is
maybe you can explain a little more
what you mean by best citizens of a
company
yeah that's a great question again most
of us we
when we work in organizations we can be
myopic we can do our job we can of
course
cooperate with other people but that
cooperation can be how shall i put it
you know episodic very project driven
and so forth
you know the best citizens of the
company are people who
um go above and beyond the call of duty
they help other people and
how do they help other people they help
other people develop their ideas they
help other people
not only develop their ideas but also to
implement them so
uh they don't get their own
self-interest in the way that's sort of
what i mean by
uh being a great citizen of a company
you always ask yourself what's good for
the institution
and then you do the right thing even
when nobody's looking at you
wonderful well thank you so much we
really appreciated having you here today
professor rao
i just want to take a few moments to do
some closing announcements
uh we will be making this webinar
available both on our youtube channel
and we'll be sending out an email
announcement when that's ready and
available
um as rony mentioned at the beginning of
the session you can download the slides
as any
at any time by clicking the print to pdf
icon
if you have any more questions please
let us know we will be
waiting to answer any of the content
questions that we didn't get to that are
still in the queue
and thank you very much for joining us
today
you